j'espère faire un film un peu différent
de ce qui a déjà été fait simplement un
important point de vue extérieur
internationale puisque d'abord je suis
belge et donc par ailleurs film est
coproduit par la rtbf donc la télévision
belge
donc il ya des choses qui sont peut-être
très connu ici mais pas connus à
l'étranger
j'ai notamment été en virginie aux états
unis pour rencontrer les ouvriers qui
avaient été intoxiqués par le
chlordécone à l'époque j'ai rencontré
là-bas des médecins et des gens au
niveau de l'administration pour voir
comment ils avaient réagi
et puis je vais jetter aussi en
allemagne où on sait que le cours des
connectivités utilisé sur la pomme de
terre
je dois encore me rendre dans d'autres
pays donc voilà ça c'est un point de vue
un peu je dirais plus large que ce qu'on
a entendu jusqu'ici vous avez visité
l'ancienne usine donc l'ancienne usine à
hopewell où était fabriqué le
chlordécone était complètement
démantelée donc il ya plus rien à voir
mais donc j'ai vu le site est là où la
pollution a démarré quoi vous travaillez
depuis six mois sur sur ce film
alors qu'est ce qu'il y aura qu est-ce
qu on verra j'espère montrer des choses
un peu différentes notamment j'ai
rencontré énormément d'acteurs ici en
martinique et en guadeloupe unie
quarantaine de personnes entourent des
élus des avocats des agriculteurs
beaucoup de monde et chacun avec des
témoignages assez différence j'ai
constaté que chacun avait sa vérité sur
ce dossier donc
donc je dirais qu'il ya pas une vérité
et c'est un peu compliqué aussi pour
faire la part des choses et vous qu'est
ce que vous voulez montrer au public
je veux montrer d'abord que j'ai
effectivement il n'y a pas qu'une seule
vérité que suivant le point de vue on se
place
on peut dire que l'état est responsable
que les les gros planteurs sont
responsables que enfin voilà il ya déjà
au niveau de la responsabilité
un gros débat là dessus et puis je
voudrais quand même donné une note
d'espoir parce que je pense que on a
peut-être il ya quelques années
exagéré la problématique on a fait peur
aux gens alors que moi là moi je suis là
depuis quatre jours je vois que les
martiniquais vivent normalement qui
continuent à vivre malgré chlordécone
s'amuse mangent les produits locaux
boivent l'eau du robinet donc je pense
qu'on a peut-être un peu amplifié cette
affaire et je voudrais faire un peu
retombée de l'adrénaline sur ce sujet